[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to another
night of chess and psychology
today is officially right around corner
for my birthday
so i thought about bringing a funny hat
but i i'm gonna save that for the actual
birthday on friday
but
i'm very excited to try and get through
all of these amazing philidor lines so
it's all gonna be over
i have i have you both on twitch and
youtube so feel free to um
say whatever you want i'll see it but
the one thing i would definitely
appreciate is donations not just because
it's close to my birthday which always
does help but because
but also because um age 75 dollar
supports a child through a full semester
of chess in san luis and well i love
chess i want more kids too no chess so
bring it
all right so um
we have been doing uh like some of my
games and analysis inspired by
the negev's book
of uh e4 versus french caracan and
philidor we talked we finished the win
awards which was a huge one i'm hoping
we'll get to wrap up philidor today and
then we can jump back into french try to
wrap that up in two or three more
sessions
so much fun
and then we're going to jump back to
karokon trying to wrap that up and um
then i'm hoping to do a mini end game
series but that's so long in the future
we can talk about that later all right
um
whoa i got a really funny comment
okay so let's go ahead and jump right
into the game
but right before we do that
i want to ask
who is who actually is in saint louis
this weekend if you are sending like a
thumbs up a heart something because i do
have few more spots available for my
in-person simultaneous uh games and it's
on saturday so if you're around or if
you want to fly down i know someone who
did
so um
we can definitely
make that happen it will be really fun
all right so without further ado let's
go to philidor so this one is going to
be more of a
line heavy style rather than my personal
games because
not too many people have played
serious games with me in philadelphia oh
thank you for the link
and
yeah
yeah there was a famous grandmaster that
is also true so you can also get to this
you can also get these lines from d6 but
i'm gonna focus on the e5 part of it now
and we will circle back and talk about
d6 later on because for these six you
know peop it's usually going to be
pierce or modern and it's a whole
different stuff but i do have a lot of
experience with those
so um let me ask you what do you think
is the most uh common way of black
playing
what do you think is the most
comfortable way black gets to play
philidor because they played d6 they
kind of um did this to themselves
troy boy i'm happy you're in a beach in
miami drinking that's wonderful
actually
um earlier today i had a little bit of a
taste of a drink called kasparov and
another drink called fabiano right in
the king side diner i mean they're nice
but
it's a really really rainy day today so
drinks not gonna be that fun
okay so i'm getting some responses i'm
having 97 knight c6 i'm having a lot of
those which is nice pawn takes is also
cool so for pawn takes i would refer you
back to the part one of the video
because we definitely talked about that
earlier
if pawn takes i'll give you a brief
overview because we went more in depth
on it g6 is cool knight f6 is cool the
thing is with g6
um you're going to play bishop g7 right
which means that in a long run you're
going to short castle but i want a long
cast though and your pawn on j6 could
become a nice target so i'm not going to
get too deep in it but i'll just give
you a brief idea of for example how the
moves could go
just as a super quick example and for
the rest of it do refer back to the part
1 philidor that we had few weeks earlier
instead of g6
knight f6 is also kind of cool whoa no
if knight f6
now as white you have this very
interesting choice because you you know
you have to figure out where you want
your king to be short castle long castle
um i'm more of a fan of having a long
castle because if we do manage to long
cast on this short castle i have a
better center my pieces are just more
comfortable i can start attacking your
king side
so
um you can start with knight c3 again
they're like interesting f3 ideas as
well
but i've never really actually tried
this in a serious game
i've always had like a um some sort of a
scare when opponent gets not scared but
i don't want the opponent to get d5
so i've never really felt that
comfortable allowing d5 to happen that
easily
so nice c3 g if opponent plays g6 again
you can do these bishop g5 ideas and try
to kind of uh get yourself more
comfortable
and
um if not g6 the other is like bishop e7
and then you can just do this really
cool idea
um and get your queen to d2 start well
not long castling that's not where i was
going with this earlier sorry
oh sorry if not knight c6 yeah if no
knight cc see if like a opponent tries
to delay it a little then you can go
long castle yeah this would be much more
comfortable because you get to simply
continue developing you're not really
committing to
making your king any weaker by moving it
anywhere or allowing opponent to attack
it easier but you are setting up shop
for h4h5 as well as trying to counter
attack opponents
attack and against your king
all right
so uh let me go back i'm not trying to
really spend too much time on this pawn
take except pawn take knight f6 is
interesting yes i agree knight d7 is
pretty cool too how do i know i feel
about knight c6
oh
leeches is doing oh my god ben remember
when they just wasn't letting me make
new moves i love it i missed that
problem
what happened recently with someone else
too
so it's not just against me okay i'm
glad to know at least it's not just me
yeah
and troy boy well she's a wgm but that's
not the point i'm showing you more of
lines rather than specific games that
have happened it's a big like mash of
both
so um i want to still be able to give
you the experience of so this is
something that happened in my game and
also give you the actual lines
all right so
um i'm going to show you a weird move
how do you feel about f5
some people do it
so how is this f5 looking
would you want to take anything over
there
g5 is an interesting choice uh opponent
is going to try and develop regardless
so bishop g5 could simply help them
develop a little bit
okay i'm getting some detached e5's i'm
getting some potential take over here
but yeah it's actually nice to just
ignore it just get your nights out
and if take you take back if d5 you just
move it and if one tries to continue
being funny well
oh it let me make it move cool you're
gonna get really wild against their king
and their squares are extremely weak so
that'll be fun for us
if h6 let me ask you what would you do
now
well you take on e5 they'll take on g5
i see an interesting potential sacrifice
thing being mentioned so i just want to
kind of circle back do you guys actually
um have that calculated
because yeah if you have to play knight
h3 that's kind of sad so if you play
this knight to g5 you have to have
something up your sleeve
take the pond chick and then maybe get
your queen and visible player well
that's kind of the problem if you take
i'll take back with the pawn on the rook
is kind of defending over here
so we can't do that
so let's talk about knight f7 let's say
we play knights f7
and after knight f7 opponent king takes
it because if they don't take it then
you're going to simply be able to eat
their um
yeah you're going to eat something
so
um let's say night of seven up one and
takes then what do you do you're
probably gonna eat this and give a check
right then let's say the king will
well let's say the king goes back then
what do you do
yeah
i think
if the king goes to e7 i'm thinking
knight g6 should just be fine
if the king tries to get too adventurous
i'm come i'm comfortable i'm very
comfortable playing like
either queen f3 and fb5 worst case
scenario i can just play g4
or if king f6 another idea that i'm kind
of playing around with is queen h5
because it would be really lovely if i
can give checks over here
so
multiple multiple options
all right
so f5 is no good but you need to know
this little trick if you don't know this
little trick and you start to like take
over here when they apply f5 i mean
taking is okay too it's not the end of
the world but you still want to be very
aware of how things are set up so if
there is a mini trap here that you can
do you should do it
alright
so
let's talk a little about knight f6
first
what should we do
yep that's completely possible uh nice
eater is also very doable the one thing
that i would not really recommend is
this
i mean
actually hold on it's possible though
because if they do take i mean if they
take here you could exchange queens and
then pick this up
and then you're threatening to pick this
up so
pretty interesting
but if they make a slight adjustment and
take uh over here then what would you do
a lot of people are hating this for
black well so do i
that's why i don't play it as black
so what do you think is a good move as
white here
that's definitely possible is that the
best one you have or is there something
more challenging that is the best one i
have okay bishop c4 is a very nice move
you're developing you're bringing more
pressure over here uh the one that i
would recommend is
yeah queen d5 would be really cool
because you're bringing more attack to
the knight you're bringing pressure over
here and then your bishop c4 would be
even more
challenging for opponent so i think this
is quite nice
and
actually how should black try and defend
this
can't really go anywhere here so it's
either maybe bishop f5
or knight c5 either way the pieces are
very misplaced
and i'm very happy about that
yeah
okay and so let's talk a little about
this knight d7
now we're talking more philidor so what
do you think we should do as white
you can kind of see that you have better
center you have slightly better
development so you want to kind of try
and keep those
little little advantages and you want to
pile them up so how can we continue
gaining little advantages
no and my reason
is wrong and later on it could be good
but the problem is that right now there
is a nice tension in the center if you
close up the center then opponent
doesn't have to yeah opponent doesn't
have to worry about it so later on
because of how the pawn structures are
set up he could try to play like f5
ideas and start attack on the center and
that's like you don't want to close up
the center too early so it's better to
keep the tension
why
you don't know where this you don't know
where this bishop belongs but you do
know where this knight and where this
bishop belongs so start with those
you might want to do bishop g5 later on
so you if you play bishop e3 then that's
a waste of move yeah that's true
but do you know where this knight wants
to be long term
they're probably um
probably c3 yeah so bring it 9c3 makes
perfect sense you could also start with
bishop c4 if i'm being honest and you
can kind of like transpose it later on
um
but i am quite comfortable with knight
c3 as is because after knight c3 let's
say opponent tries to
develop normally then what do you do
we could do bishop g5 but again it feels
like it's a little too early to commit
to this bishop
exactly yeah this is a great diagonal
for our bishop we want this bishop to be
here
now i'm going to kind of
take a second i'm going to flip the
board and i'm going to ask you to try
and come up with some long-term ideas
for black
such a weird look from now
i had such great center and space when
now i flipped the board
all right
i see a lot of people are also
mentioning g4 yes g4 is a very
interesting tactical
um development in philidor but
that's not something that's not as
common
uh it's very doable but you kind of
gotta know what you're doing
i agree nikki who would play this a lot
of people do and they feel comfortable
because you know they're not really
putting up a fight in the center yet but
they have every intention to do so later
on so how do you think what do you think
like if black
has five moves what are those five moves
going to be and no like it can't be just
easier ethere's here not that
e7
okay so that's two of them what else do
you got
there should still
go to b6 and hit that bishop and they
give him time to mess with the center
and then that lets his other bishop out
possible but not necessarily the best
one because your knight up here would
kind of be useless when the bishop moves
away so i agree on your first two ideas
okay the chat is uh
coming up with some really cool ideas i
agree
potential for c6
yeah exactly you need to have some sort
of a counter to play you need to be able
to attack something so uh you're you're
going to do shortcast though so is white
white is also going to be doing short
castle
and um black has some potential ideas
around here
well last that's a little longer because
we still want to like we want to be
realistic about okay if i have that b5
idea or if i have this d5 idea i'm quite
content with it so i can just kind of
hold it as is but if i need to um start
worrying about you know i can't do
anything in the center now that's a huge
problem all right so i'm going to bring
back
ah this is so much nicer
oof yeah
yeah
this reminds me from a scene i'm a
bummer fan of the friends tv show i
remember there was a scene that it was
on thanksgiving and like joey had wanted
to like eat a huge bird and he went and
got like phoebe's maternity pants and he
could like stretch in it because it was
so comfortable i think he ate the whole
thing i don't remember exactly about
that part but this but this kind of like
looking at it from this aspect makes me
like okay
i can deep take a deep breath
but
yeah i don't really like it when i don't
have center
alright so uh black has a few ideas they
can take over here they can try to just
develop
and
then knight to b6 that you mentioned is
i mean also possible later on
but
alicia's won't make me do it so we'll
talk about it later
yeah joy does have goals i don't know
how he wasn't exploding in that tv show
but
now
yes
so let me ask you what if they take
does that change anything are you still
gonna do long do short castle um in
close future or are you gonna start
considering lawn castle
question about the classic code or is it
okay to trade queens early um
if you're eating ponds i would say yes
but if you are
um not eating ponds and you're kind of
just getting into that endgame no i i
actually had a game like that against
nazi pakistan
the position was going good but she
really
truly taught me a lesson
so
so if you want to keep your options open
what are you going to take that pawn
back with
queen is
like
i agree queen taste is quite nice
because there is no more knight c6 to
attack your coin and even if they do see
fives then they're weakening this pawn
weakening this square i'm totally fine
with that
all right so
queen takes d4 opponent could um try to
maybe play like bishop
that is not the position i was going for
sorry
huge huge spoiler alert
um black could try to go bishop e7 and
if they do then we can try and get
bishop out long castle and now this was
actually quite interesting because i
didn't i i i always used to just kind of
see if i could move this bishop away and
you know start attacking but we can't
let this bishop be and you can play like
quirky one which is so weird because you
know you want to be attacking the king
when there's opposite side castles but
exactly yeah because how much control
over center you have it does make sense
to just develop and i'm going to go one
step further and kind of blow your mind
how do you feel about bishop back to f1
exactly well i don't think i'm blowing
your mind i think nagi would be the one
who did the blowing
but bishop f1 is quite nice because
it's like sorry
yes
but not just that it's weird because
i i try to explain it to my students but
i don't think i always
get through when i'm talking about
bishops so bishops are kind of as long
as they have you know they have they
have some control over a diagonal they
are not undeveloped you kind of move the
bishops to put them in like better
diagonals
or
you you move them to you know activate
the rook so if the rook is already out
there you don't need the bishop to be
out there if there is no good spot for
it
so it's kind of a weird concept to think
of the bishop being already developed
where it is but that's true you don't
need to move it if you already have
everything you want from it so if you
know you move the bishop to do you know
you move the bishop to the short castle
but if you already castle you don't need
to do that you move the bishop to get
the rook out but the rook is already out
so hallelujah and if he had swapped that
would have gave him more essential
control with the pond than the open air
file
yeah if it did take you're correct
ah
it would take back and then they would
have some potential attacks in the
center so i agree
that's not a good idea to take so thanks
all right
uh
question is there benefit to f1 clearly
there is compared to d or e well i mean
if you go here you're blocking over here
if you go um if you go here you're well
exactly yeah you don't want almost force
to go back there on b3
yeah bishop b3 would also give some
potentials for double
i'm even thinking maybe this could work
and just trap the bishop
it could be very unpleasant if that does
happen
all right
um
so let's just go back i just want to
share this really cool bishop of online
now if they take take you know they
don't have to play uh they can
they don't have to to play weird they
can also let us play e5 which would be
perfect for us
uh but all right let's get back to
bishop e7 because i'm trying to give you
as much as i can for philidor because i
really don't want to filter part three
all right so what is what should we do
now is it time to just short castle or
should we get this bishop out
i apologize to the rook i'm sure that
bishop did
i would naturally go to knight g5
because knight g5 they would just
probably castle and say thank you right
because you're not gonna be taking that
there's already two defenders on it so
what else do you got
bishop g5 is indeed a possibility but
um
in my limited classical experience with
philidor
it's is very important to have the exact
right move order because if you don't
opponent
then opponent kind of manages manages to
catch you with c6 b5
and that's you want to avoid being
caught off guard
um so it's important to start with a4
because the whole thing that we did was
that opponent wants to do this right
we'll take it away from them that's my
whole chest philosophy figure out what
opponent wants to do and block it
all right so now let me ask you if they
take
what has changed do we still want to
take with the queen
do we intend to do lawn castle
because if not you're going a short
castle so you don't need your queen to
be out there just yet it could be but
i don't think queen is bad but it does
kind of makes it a little bit wonderful
because when you take with knight you
also have potentials for knight to five
and i do like that more and let's say
castle castle knight t5 now you can just
move the bishop away and this is a very
comfortable position
of course there is so much more to it
but this is a permanent weakness this is
a permanent weakness this is a bad
bishop so you have little advantages
here and there that
do add up so
cool
all right i'm gonna make a huge jump
back
and talk about castle all right now what
is it finally time to castle or do we
want to still continue moving these
i guys well you know you're going to
castle king's house since you don't
download pretty much
i don't i guess if you knew the best
place to put the bishop that would be a
great place
yep so you have two options for your
bishop but i agree it's we don't
necessarily want to rush it let's just
castle because you're not going to be
doing long castle anymore so let's just
get the king out of the way
um so after castle opponent has
especially with your opponent four
opponent has two interesting ways to go
they should still do something because
if not then they don't really have
enough space to breathe right
right so
c6 or a6 those two would be the
interesting choices because um black
can't really do much stuff in the king
side but they could try to set up stuff
for queen side slash center
so it does make sense to explore c6 and
a6 a bit more
let's start with
which one i want to start let's start
with a6
c5
well that's the thing even if c5s do
happen um
that that also proves to be difficult
for a point because they do give this
outpost to us that's it's a permanent um
weakness for them
all right so let's let's talk about a6
long term what do you think a6 uh is
hoping to achieve
also um thank you
chat
bahubali sorry can't really such a tiny
phone
yeah but it's also trying it's also
hoping to achieve this
that is true but long term long term
they do want to achieve this so how can
we try to continue blocking opponents
hopes and dreams
yeah
i have no idea who said that
that too no more no more jumping horses
yeah i like a5 and now opponents you
know can choose to take which we can
easily just take back and if they try to
get funny with their nights it's totally
fine we'll continue to take away their
hopes and dreams i like that can we
change the title to dorset takes hopes
and dreams away from opponents
or that's a good book title for the next
one
but yeah i like this because you just
kind of
h3 serves no purpose for your position
but it takes away a lot of the things
that opponent is hoping to achieve so
i like that
i don't yeah it's prophylactic but it's
more of a like a knowing thing because
you know sometimes people play h3
because i asked them why they're like
well later on in the end game i want my
king to have something so that's more of
a perfect yeah i feel like that's more
what i understand is perfect but this is
just you know it's like
you know like little kids when they uh
somebody
you know they do something and they ask
why did you do it then they do
this this kind of feels like that i
don't know what's that called in english
though
i have no idea
i can just make it so
yeah
so i feel like that's kind of um that's
the reason behind h3 try to explain that
to somebody
um
well
that's i don't think that's that's fair
we're not trying to do g4 we're just
trying to take away g4 from opponents
yeah
we're trying to be mean
yeah so a stream that's upon tries to
continue and you're just gonna get the
rest of your pieces out you're going to
again continue bothering them as much as
you humanly can
and now again
you're you're just developing you're not
you're not really setting up anything
super special but you know this is a
weak pawn this is something that could
happen this is another weak pawn your
bishop is much better than their bishop
i think our knights are relatively
similar but you know there is a lot of
problems in their position they're just
really annoyed
so
um
let me go
a while back
i just i just wanted to show that for
example even if knight to e5 you could
oh
come on leeches
okay even if 95 you can just take and
eat upon and i'm quite happy with that
even if they tried to get like g4 in
earlier then they're leaving this square
so we can start jumping there
nikki if you played this knight p6
earlier that could happen i mean it
could be
um
but
not
i mean
we're kind of looking into a different
idea and especially with a6 when we play
a5 there goes their knight b6 forever
and you know even if this happens i'm
quite comfortable with this position
um the problem is that this bishop is
so useless the only thing it's doing is
trying to defend and that's fair is
defending but
this bishop if it was here our position
would not be as comfortable so
cool
um
all right i'm gonna make another huge
jump back
and i i mean after a5 the best move for
black is technically h6 but you can
continue playing this h3 to annoy them
and you know you can just the same
things could happen and i'm not really
um
too worried about it
but all right so i'm gonna just make
another jump back let's talk c6 or a bit
i'm really hoping to wrap up philidor
today
so what should white do
yes that is one of the great ones
your rook does belong only one you're
not drunk but um
that's not the best move order
i mean that's also a possibility
um i think that's okay too
but the the main one is this one
exactly
exactly i don't know exactly i don't
know if i can make that happen again
i need a clip from that i guess but yeah
it's true would be that and you're
taking away you know you're gaining more
control over the g4 square and um
let's say opponent
goes ahead and oh
okay let's start with this what if they
take it
because they played c6 so they have d5
support will you take that back
i might go bishop captain fine take the
intake
if you do that you're kind of giving
center to opponent and you're also kind
of
opening up the rook don't be nice to
your opponent yeah that's true
what else do we have we should probably
take that right so let's say we take it
they played d5 now what do we do
well that's not the choice do you want
to keep the bishop or do you want to
keep the knights there's the third
option but
the third option would be you let them
both stay here and you try to get an
opponent's head and make them choose
[Music]
i mean i don't think being a pawn down
at the moment is such a huge
heartbreaker because
you are going to be able to get that
pawn back
so
how do you feel about rookie one
if they take over here okay your rook
will take
and
you have two bishops well actually they
have to be ships too that wasn't fair
you have two active bishops there we go
and they have two really awkward bishops
and yes you're technically still upon
down and i mean if you chose to you
could eat over here but if you do then
opponent could start to poke you back
so i kind of like this more and even if
they try to defend it that's okay
because we have such a great
um
momentum
uh that we're just gonna be able to kind
of write it
and i really like this
i'm very sad i've never got gotten a
game in philadelphia
um
so that was kind of a i just wanted to
mention this and you know even if they
do funny business like this whoa come on
leeches okay we can do bishop g5 start
poking the queen they move it we move it
it's going to be a beautiful mess
but it's messy but like it's good for us
because uh opponent is trying to defend
this platform it's trying to develop but
we're trying to get our pieces out and
we know where we want to go with the
pieces so this makes so much more sense
for us than it does for our plants
all right
um let's talk maybe
after rookie one let's see what if they
eat this guy
what do we do
hello diggs
so they're still doing this
uncomfortable fork
we are going to be giving one of those
pieces back but
what do you think well how do you think
we should do that
well
you take here they could take this and
then if you take it they could maybe try
to trade off nights and i don't want to
make my parents
their life easy and help them develop
let me ask you this um
how do you feel about giving opponent
some isolated pawns
i guess i said the double pawns
yeah they're easier to attack they're
easier to eat harder for opponent to
defend
and even if they do try and defend it
then we are simply going to be able to
develop the way we want
and you know i think this is a slightly
more comfortable position for black than
most of the other lines we've seen but
um
you know it's a very weak pawn it's
really easy to attack
you have no um
do you i can't think of any weaknesses
you have i mean i guess this pawn
could be slightly you know attackable
but even then they would have to
relocate their knight to be able to
attack this so that you could just push
it
uh i think this is quite comfortable all
right i'm gonna make a huge jump to here
and ask what if they
took the bishop then what
push or eat
but
this is a central plum
yeah we should eat it
oh will be great we'll just take it back
and if they move their knights now we
have a new square that we can consider
um
jumping into
and even if they do take well amazing i
can just take with the pawns
yeah
yeah i do like having that pawn up there
all right i'm gonna make another huge
jump back
so let's say they don't take it let's
say they play something a little
different how do you feel about like
maybe a5
a little weird but how do you feel about
it
nice
well what are you gonna do
okay so what do you think white should
do
should we get this truck crawling
no we can't do rookie one
there are other options too you can move
this bishop away you can move this
bishop up but rookie one is uh good
and
sorry
b3
after a5s
but i mean what do you do if knight b6
happens
there is a very nice thing about a
street i'll show you in a second but if
a5 does happen your bishop is totally
fine here and you can simply develop
from the uh the other material
and this is really comfortable your
bishop is so strong over here i don't
think you have much to worry about for
that bishop at least and even if
something like that happens again you
have a nice attack your rook can join
the party too so i'm gonna leave it here
for um this specific line with a5
and i will be sharing this stock uh well
this link afterwards hopefully if i can
figure out how and so you can try and
get deeper
if you need to
and let's say uh let's say no a5 let's
say they play
um
i mean h6 h6 is so weird you can just
rookie one and two
and then you can just continue
developing if they let you a5 would be
wonderful as well
how about rook uh how about another
sticks let's say go uh b6 what do you
think about b6
bye
it does but it also has some ideas so
don't don't underestimate it
i think it would be comfortable if we
finally do why we did this h3 which is
to do this
so we're trying to kind of um
surprise the opponent a little bit
because this keeps happening in
philadelphia and i just want to go so
when this happens everybody always plays
rookie one so black knows what they're
doing but with queen e2 rook d1 it's a
little bit um
kind of more fun
and um you know you can simply get your
bishops in the safe spot so you can
continue developing even if stuff
happens there boom b4
i'm not in this position but i've had
experiences with closing up this side
and it's so uncomfortable i love it
i believe it wasn't sicilian actually
but i kept doing it
let's say for example opponent goes
rookie eight
what do you think white should do
yeah completely possible and then
they're gonna move and you can try and
take take and
start attacking
it nice
um
let's see anything else that i think
it's worth oh there's a really cool
bishop b7 idea so there should be seven
opponent wants to you know set up shop
for a aaa file so
how do you think we can um
kind of bother them not make it too easy
for them
exactly this should be three yep
it's kind of weird to think about it but
bishop on b3 it's not that it's not
doing anything it's beginning to take
more control over here and you know if
they play rook a8 and we don't let we
don't combat it they'll try to pile up
here i don't want that to happen so i
would much rather just exchange it and
if the rook takes i always have this
again
i could i could actually start with d5
and then try to open up a little and now
there is
a
bunch of new stuff i can attack
so let's see
so yeah that's that bishop b3 i thought
it was worth mentioning even if like
knight beast even if like um knight b6
you can again do bishop b3
and again try and explore these
weaknesses around here because you have
better development that's a very um
important point to figure out when to
resolve the tension in the center
because if you do it too early there
goes your chances if you do it too late
opponents could gain control and return
so even if they play like h6 you can go
again bishop b3 and now let me ask you
is it time to try and go maybe d5 or
take or something
okay um
let's say we push
let's say they let's say they don't take
it let's say they're going to b6 what do
we do then
damn it
you're gonna give up your
no you're beautiful bishop no no no
don't give it up
but it's such a good bishop
poor bishop
but like you can actually eat this pond
so you had the right you said the right
thing you want to eat but
yeah
exactly
what about take if they do take now what
we have a bunch of stuff we can take
i think the problem with that is i mean
it's definitely possible but they're uh
yeah they'll move the queen and then
later on they'll have bishop b7 to
continue attacking your knight
well that's another good point
even if that wasn't the case even if you
could magically try and trap this queen
which actually that can't happen yeah
that was a
i agree
what about something more simple just
knight takes take back rook takes
well your bishop wouldn't be serving
much of a function up there
but your rook now is attacking over here
attacking over here
if a pawn tries to defend it now another
cool move and i think this will be our
last move for now because we gotta
switch to i guess because we're already
on twitch but we do have to start
getting to analyze your game so how do
you feel about c4
it's kind of weird right
if they take you take back it's so weird
because you have this past pawn but they
can take it but then you get bishop p5
and their queen is quite in trouble they
move it boom you go after it again they
move it nice you take that
and
final move of the this position again of
course nobody's ever going to you know
memorize all this and have it happen to
you
so
what is this
blaspheme for white
beautiful good job
and if they well if they don't take
their knight is really our night is
really amazing attacking this if they do
take then we get devil rooks up there
attacking this i love this position
yeah this was wonderful um
the link will be in the the description
later on so you can have access to
affiliate doors and some of the winners
that we've done so far
and we're gonna take a tiny break get
your games in
um
and restart backup on twitch so that
will be bye-bye to my youtube people but
do come to twitch bring a game for me to
your alliance don't forget it's gotta be
on lince's format and oh yes don't
forget to donate because it's my
birthday not today in two days but still
you won't see me so bring it up
all right bye everybody
[Music]
you